You're implying that's the case is because you're an Islamophobic
hag. His name is Hassan.
>> When has Kyle Kolinsky ever been a part of the Democratic
Party coalition in a meaningful way? >> This guy was doing
whippets in the back of a Volkswagen Beetle while Kyle Klinsky
was doing Democratic politics, getting super blasted and hitting
360 nocopes in Call of Duty while Kyle Klinsky was actually doing
political work. And this guy goes, "When are you a part of the
coalition?" This guy has the survival instincts of like a blind
paralyzed thawn.
What we're going to do is we're going to get into this Hutch
stuff, okay? Cuz I grabbed my own video. Grabbed the the Riyle
Kitten House video on the old on the old back and forth. Okay,
so Hutch and Kyle Kolinsky have this little back and forth. Here
we go. There's a comment. There's a donation
on Kyle Kolinsky's live stream. Yo, Kyle Hutch be criticizing
your criticism of Democrats, but they're good faith and interesting.
So, I'd love to see another KKF debate with him soon.
Alinsky and friends maybe saying that Kyle is is annoyed with
Hutch or whatever. Is the same the guy who donated to Hutch saying
that is the same guy who donated to Kyle says, "Yo, Kyle, Hutch
be criticizing your criticisms of Democrats." What happened is
Hutch's editor, so-called, apparently clickbaited a title, kind
of implying Kyle like never ever criticized anybody else, constantly
equates Democrats to Republicans, which I don't believe Kyle
does. All right. And Hutch did that. He coped about it. And Kyle
was like, "Yeah, you Hutch you, man. You
okay?" So that was, you know, the summation of the drama really
quickly, but they had some drama. This was five months ago.
And that leads us to today where Hutch gets Hutch is going to
watch Kyle Klinsky's video on Hana. I didn't get a chance to
watch this video, but I'm glad we get to watch it through Hutch's
point of view now. Very excited for this. Very, very excited.
Should be a good time. All right, y'all. I have to say I am uh
completely and utterly done with Hassan derangement syndrome.
Uh, let me just say uh as clear as I possibly can, if you are
a political
>> and you have a take on Hassan [__] do me
a favor and just shut the up.
>> And obviously he's excluded from this, >> uh I
don't want to hear it. Nobody wants to hear it. Uh we shouldn't
even be having this conversation. this whole >> well I
think Kyle would argue you know not unlike Iran he's been provoked
into defensive attacks on people okay he doesn't want this not
unlike Iran Kyle is a truly peaceful individual hopefully will
be the last >> why not >> time I have to >> what
do you mean I thought isn't this the point of
>> discourse isn't this the point of
why would we >> apparently not apparently if you say guys
if you're in a competitive place you should vote blue no matter
who. But I personally have problems with the administration.
So in my state where it's safe, I'm going to vote for somebody
else. Apparently you can't have that conversation. Why would
you be able to have this conversation? Hutch not be having this
conversation if this is a conversation about the future of the
Democratic party. What are you expecting liberals to do? Just
like sit back and
not opine on something that they have feelings about. Address
this.
But I am so sick. We're living in a world where Donald Trump
is waging an illegal and offensive war against Iran. The outline
of World War II is there. This is I guess this is the new like,
you know, there's a genocide in Gaza.
I guess
they're switching it up and they're going with this now. Like
don't talk about this
because there's a genocide in Gaza. Don't talk about this because
Donald Trump is, you know,
threatening Iran with uh
>> civilizational destruction. Yes. Yeah.
He really said it. He really said he really said, "Guys, they're
trying to pressure me into not talking about Hassan just cuz
Trump's trying to do a
>> Well, guess what? I am gonna talk about Assad all stream
today >> because Donald Trump is I guess
there's >> also nobody
nobody's saying he can't talk about this. I would just say, you
know,
probably seek out some different opinions. Go and argue about
this on streams. Go and like seek out Yeah. different opinions
and argue with those people.
Why not?
>> Switching it up and they're going with this now. Like
don't talk about this
because there's a genocide in Gaza. Don't talk about this because
Donald Trump is, you know,
threatening Iran with uh
civilizational destruction.
>> I don't know why he did the face. Very >> Why
Why can't we talk about both the both these things at the same
time? Like, do you really think that Trump being really >> You
could. It just probably
like it probably reveals your preferences what you want to talk
about. That's all right. I I would think >> bad means that
Hassan [__] is
>> exempted from criticism. Is that really what you're
suggesting? Uh >> has Hutch come up with a new criticism?
>> I feel like Hutch has just been watching Saw and like
about him a lot. >> Maybe not. Maybe. Maybe I stumbled
on to a very very niche stream where Hutch covers us on for 3/4
of the stream length and that's not something that happens regularly.
>> like if that's like a once a week thing and otherwise
Hutch is always on politics
like if the if the broad base of his content is just like nothing
related to Hassan at all then okay
I don't even mind like if Hutch if Hutch is doing this like once
a week okay that's fine >> I mean why can't I flip that
around on you why can I not use the same exact logic on you like
Kyle why are you doing a video about Hassan there's you know
Trump is threatening Iran therefore [__] sure anybody
Well, that's the point he's making. And he also did a bunch of
content on the Iran side >> with a functioning brain can
see it. China, Russia, Iran versus US and Israel with a hesitant
Europe to take a side. Even the Gulf Arab states now are hesitant
to sort of take a side. You see the outlines there. The straight
of Hormuza shut down. Gas is absolutely skyrocketing. Our AI
bubble is about to burst seemingly any minute. We have war crime
after war crime after war crime being committed on a daily basis.
We have fears of a MOAB or nukes about to be used in Iran. They're
attacking hospitals. They're attacking schools. Israel is stealing
South Lebanon right now as we speak. They displace 1.1 million
people. They're bulldozing their homes. They're seizing their
land. ALL THIS IS GOING ON. And we're supposed to have a conversation
about Hassan [__] Did you >> Why would we not
have a conversation about the future of the Democratic party?
Kyle,
why is that conversation off limits? >> Uh, I don't think
it's off limits. But you literally are trying to go actually
now is the perfect time to say that this guy whose signature
policy is, hey, he's anti-Israel. The thing people know Hassan
for is being anti-Israel. And it turns out all the things Kyle
listed, lots of them are reasons Israel's monstrous
and he's sort of been vindicated. Hassan, people feel like Hassan
has been vindicated. Hassan's side on the Israel question has
been vindicated to a large extent. And so when you go after Hassan
and specifically the third way stuff is going after him for anti-semitism,
you look insane. It is damaging to your party. It is damaging
to your credibility as as Democratic operators, right? As Democrat
operators, I should say, not not operators in a democracy, but
operators who further the goals of the Democratic party. It makes
you look bad. That's the point. That's the point. All these people
Well, Kyle might be making like different points slightly, but
that is the core point with the whole third wave thing.
I hate this this these tricks that they try to pull. They try
to like guilt people into not having important and necessary
conversations.
By the way, like people were kind of laughing at Hutch for being
totally disproportionate in how he covered things before, but
it wasn't until the third way people like this this outside sort
of special interest group came in and started trying to cancel
Hassan that all these other influencers sort of closed ranks
around Hassan and went no off. No, get the out of here. Right?
So, this wasn't something Hutch was like being, you know, excoriated
over. I thought he was absurd. A lot of people thought he was
absurd, but nobody's saying you can't talk about this. It's just
like, oh, the focus seems a little odd, right? But now it's like,
okay, now Kyle has this opinion because outside like third parties
are coming in and trying to manufacture a narrative against Assan.
One that I think Hutch doesn't even agree with.
Well, sorry, Hutch does agree with it, but now I believe Hutch
will fall back from it because the person who gives him his opinions
also fell back from it. They devised these conditions that in
their minds through their rhetoric they're expressing that they
feel like basic and it's not just Assan like he's saying like
they I think I think this goes bigger than Hassan
he's making the case that they should not be criticized for what
for anything like we just like don't talk about these things
that I think are
so like for example America was trying to do what do you call
like a counter tent they wanted to do do like a countervent for
Hassan's event that he's doing in Michigan right now
like that trying to trying to do that seems like totally totally
moronic right
obviously are actually pretty important um
Babza with the tier 2 membership council of non-democrats are
forming the Democratic party into their own image do not criticize
this council while it is in motion thank you that's a good way
of putting it yeah do not question them
judgment is not to be questioned their judgment their rhetoric
their actions. Do not criticize them. >> You are totally
free to do your criticisms of Kyle right here. Explain when he
when he lays out his vision, he's saying I think with all these
other things going on, it doesn't make a lot of sense to focus
on Hassan [__]
right? I mean, I'll further Well, no, I won't further it yet.
We'll let Kyle make his own arguments. He's saying I don't think
it makes sense. I assume he's going to say some other stuff.
>> Why? Because Donald Trump really? Okay. Well, what did
you guys do? Do can you say can Kyle Kolinsky and Han [__]
look in the mirror and say with a clear conscience that they
did everything in their power to stop Donald Trump from winning
the second term? I don't think either of them get to do that.
So, the fact that they think that they should somehow be immune
from criticism at this point now
is uh a bit ironic, a bit silly. Skeptical ninja with $5. It
would be funny to call his bluff if he would say the same about
um negative discourse around destiny.
Guaranteed he's too ass.
I would believe this from Kyle if he would defend my my my best.
If he would defend Destiny, I would totally believe this from
Kyle. Yeah. No,
Kyle thinks Desty's like a demon. Kyle doesn't like Destiny.
I don't know what else to tell you. Okay. Kyle was perfectly
fine with Desty's audience, but Destiny himself, he wants nothing
to do with obviously. Dude, it's so funny how this all goes back
to Israel Palestine every single time. And that's why
that's pain to bite that bullet. >> We keep going. >> Well,
he wouldn't do that because he doesn't actually believe this.
He doesn't actually believe that people should be immune from
criticism. This is all like a game. A kind of a silly game. >> you
guys see that in 2019 he said this thing which was really politically
incorrect and rude. I don't give a [__] if he was
having with your grandma in 2019 or 2012. I don't give a Why
are we having this conversation? Why are >> Why do you
think we're having this conversation? Steal me on that argument.
Why do you think people are talking about Hassan [__]
>> I want to hear Can Hutch lay it out. Why do you think
they're talking about Hassan [__] Cuz it's not for
the reasons you picked. Just guess. Hutch has like a whole different
argument for why you should like hate Hassan than the third way
people, right? It's a totally different topic. But he doesn't
understand or he's intentionally like willfully dismissing what's
actually happening, what the broader conversation is about. >> You
know what Hassan is
has made and I've given him flowers for this recently and I've
meant it sincerely like he's done a really him and the people
that represent him or whoever is lining up these interviews and
appearances. He's had a much more aggressive schedule in terms
of going into other spaces that is smart. It's savvy and I think
it's benefited him a lot. But I think like in in the recent the
last like couple of years, he's made more of an effort to actually
try to have some influence
>> within Democratic party politics like beyond just like
sitting in a a chair and doing a live stream. He has like deliberately
consciously
been trying to put himself out there more to have more influence
in Democratic Party politics. >> Okay. Well, he has said
a lot of stuff that very much gives the impression that he is
not actually interested in helping the Democratic party win elections
in a holistic sense.
>> That's is that what he's being attacked for? Do you
think that's what he's being attacked for, Hutch? See, it's like
it's super Weasley. It's super Weasley. He said a lot of things
about But that's not what he's being attacked for saying, is
it? He's not being attacked for saying
it's weird that they would they would not let a Palestinian protester
speak at the DNC. He's not being attacked for that. >> He
regards the Democratic Party rather
uh antagonistically
in a very in a very hostile kind of way. He's he like very actively
publicly hostile to 95% of elected Democrats. And >> unfortunately
on one specific issue, 95% of elected Democrats deserve criticism.
Kyle doesn't think that it's appropriate for Democrats to ask
the question of like, should we pander to this guy?
Should we pander him and coddle him and try to try to woo him
into the tent? How is that not a relevant question? Why would
it would be insane if we didn't have that conversation?
I would be worried if we didn't have that conversation.
Um, do you think he starts to implode or gets or get exposed
with all this mainstream attention? I don't think this attention
is going well for him. I don't think it's good for a hunt to
have clips of him talking about America deserving 911
showing up on Fox News and
why is it bad?
What's what's the downside?
I actually don't know what the downside is. It sucks that like
people get the wrong impression of him, but anybody who's going
to tune in is going to see that like a different stream. No,
I think I think that's what he's betting on is, hey, if I just
keep doing content, if I just keep covering the news, saying
my political thoughts, and it's not like just that, then people
will love it. People will love it. They'll come, they'll stay,
and it'll be >> MSNBC and pool work. Like, I don't think
it's good for his um brand. I don't think it's good for his image.
I think he knows that. >> I think it probably rattles him
a little bit. Let's grow up here. Move the on. Let's not talk
about his song. So, Tim Miller comes out and says that. Well,
you have a right-wing Democrat, a diet maggot Democrat, as I
call him, uh Sarah Longwell. She was one of the founders of the
bullwark, I believe, and she was mad at Tim Miller and she goes,
"Well, we got to have this conversation on here cuz I don't agree
with you." What followed was just one of the most frustrating
conversations I think I've ever seen. So, let me show you a little
snippet here. Here's what she said. It's like why we're picking
this fight with him now? I'm just like I could think of a thousand
other things I would rather Democrats pick fights about now.
Like why him right now? >> Because he's making their life
harder. It is m people like Hassan are hold on. People like Assan
are making Democrats who want to take a stand against this war,
right? And who want to take probably take a stand against the
way that Trump is just sort of like, you know, doing whatever
BB tells him. They're trying to figure out how to do it in a
way where they don't imperil the safety of people in this country.
They're trying to do it in a way that is they don't want to be
anti-mitic. And I'll tell you why Hassan is so dangerous is that
what it does is it's exactly what Trump does. It's exactly what
Nick Fuentes does. Tucker does. It takes maybe legitimate rage
about something and then it gives them an enemy to put it on.
It gives them an an outgroup to blame for it. And I think you
have to be so careful with that so that you're not doing that,
which starts with condemning the people who hold the same position
as you for reasons that are bad, for reasons that are hostile
totally disagree. Totally disgree. It starts with condemning
the war and condemning Israel and condemning BB and condemning
Trump and being passionate and clear about it. Cuz then what
happens? Then if you have the credibility then with the voters
who who are anti-war voters who are unhappy about the way that
they see the bipartisan establishment. They thought Trump was
going to be their their savior from this that there was this
some blob in DC. No matter which parties in charge, we always
get the stupid. If Tim is making the point that attacking Hassan
over Israel is not tactically smart in this moment, but there
are other things that you can legitimately go after him for,
then I agree. But if Tim is making the point that you shouldn't
even talk about Hassan because Hassan is seen as, you know,
No, but not even Kyle is really making that point. Kyle Kyle
might say it cuz Kyle speaks in straight lines. Kyle's doing
like a leftwing Trump thing. Like not that he's a degenerate
liar, you know, criminal.
Not any of those things about Kyle. I'm just saying that for
Kyle,
he's speaking in very concise, very small bursts that everybody
can understand. He is trying to say things in a way that like
everybody gets and he is leaving things out. He's leaving nuance
out a lot of the time and just speaking in like a hyperbolic
way because he's he's making, you know, mass appeal content.
But I think if you had a more nuanced conversation with Kyle,
he would not say, "Oh, you can't talk about Hassan ever." That's
not really his opinion, even though he said it that way, right?
He's saying his his way of explaining this is it's how Trump
communicates, too. Trump finds the side of the issue he's going
to take and then he hyperbolizes his own position. He says he
goes like way past even the people who are advocating for something.
Like, I love Bitcoin so much. Sometimes I've said, "We shouldn't
even have money. We should just have Bitcoin." Like that, right?
Like he's talking to an audience. He will go above and beyond
and like go way, right? He'll go super hyperbolic. very very
hyperbolic on things and Kyle's doing the same thing. Well, I'm
not what he's saying is you should probably not give into this
this framing set up by Third Way and all this, but the way it
comes out is if you think you have an opinion on Hassan, shut
the up. Don't even talk right now, right? That's that's how it
comes out. >> Someone who's been very vocal about anti-Israel
stuff, then I disagree with >> Good wars. They thought
Trump was their way out of this. And now that Trump's doing the
same [__] that all the other ones did that we said
we didn't want it. He's doing it worse. And so now >> Tim's
not even a Democrat, right? I don't know. I think he might be
a Democrat. He's definitely a former >> The Democrats go
to those people and go on those show. They should be on those
shows. Democrats should be begging Joe Rogan or whoever to have
them on right now. They should be on Manosphere shows being like,
"I told you this was stupid. I didn't want to do this. This war
is dumb. Our relationship with Israel is too tight. We should
be reevaluating it. We should not be let getting dogwalked into
this war. By the way, NBS also sucks, right?" Like you can do
that in a way that's not anti-mic is what has happened. He's
right that the same people who basically were like, "OH, WE MESSED
UP BY NOT treating Joe Rogan like a special little baby bird
and going on his show and explaining things to him like he's
three years old." Uh, they were they're now in retrospect, they
go, "Oh, we should have been open to the podcasters and the bro
sphere. WHY WOULDN'T WE BE OPEN to them? We're so dumb. That's
how you gain the voters. You go where they are. Like he's got
a lot of people listening. We should have went over there." Those
same people are now shunning the left-wing Joe Rogan. They're
going, "I'M GOING TO CANCEL HIM. I DON'T LIKE HIM. He needs to
shut up and never say anything I don't like ever." And let me
quote the worst things he ever said, but out of context and make
him sound like an absolute maniac. Even though anybody WHO WATCHES
HIS SHOW FOR ONE DAY OR TWO CAN IMMEDIATELY tell you that the
way they try to portray him is psychotically inaccurate to the
point where they're >> I mean some of the again some of
the attacks against Assan I would say have been disingenuous.
Some of them have been genuine smears.
>> I So again
I need more examples when Hutch says this cuz that is worthless
to admit in and of itself. Right. I need you to tell me what
are the disingenuous smears against Hassan.
Hutch, what do you think are the disingenuous smears? I'm gonna
take two off the table right away. Okay, broth one and anything
about Paris Jackson off the table. Don't do those ones because
no serious political creator is doing those. Now tell me which
are the dangerous smears. The brothel one is easy cuz it's obviously
not true. Or sure sure the diddy one. I'm saying like politically
what are the smears? But okay. All right. Some of them seem to
be the result of like lazy
research on Hassan,
but I, you know, if you, if you genuinely do watch a lot of Hassan's
content, he he does come across as quite psychotic
very frequently. The video that we watched yesterday where he
was talking about Stacy Kay was one of the most psychotic things
I've ever seen in my life. Following her exact game >> on
to campaigning with Liz Cheney. Tim Miller is the only never
Trumper who has actually truly thought about what happened in
2024. That's he's making the case that, you know, people shouldn't
listen to Sarah Longwell because she doesn't know how to win
elections. But again, there's no reflection of like does how
are justice stems doing these days? You know, we had two DSA
endorsed members of Congress after the 2018 midterms and 8 years
later there are still just two DSA endorsed
uh politicians in Congress. What how have they like I don't understand
the impulse that they have. I mean,
I do think like downstream of the Justice Dems and AOC is is
Mum Donnie for one thing, right? And I unfortunately I think
downstream was also kind of Federman.
I think a lot of those guys really like Federman when he was
first running. No, I have to give advice. Incredible. So Sarah
Longwell supported the idea of campaigning with Liz Cheney. Now
she has the nerve to police the boundaries and the borders. I
mean, the fact that he even thinks that Liz Cheney made any difference
at all in in the election,
>> oh, Liz Cheney made a difference. Li the Liz Cheney
thing reverberated through popular culture. Does this guy not
remember what Liz Cheney
like what the reaction was in popular culture? It's just crazy.
>> In a bad way, like the fact that he thinks that doing
two campaign stops with Liz Cheney lost a single vote in this
entire country is a product of him being a I think just like
this Yeah, it's the exact same minimization of people's like
how they feel about stuff that always happens. Oh, but she just
did two stops. They talked about it. It was a media cycle. People
defended it. People acted like it wasn't just a weird thing to
do. Like it wasn't some kind of betrayal. It was that person
sucks. Everybody Everything to do with her sucks and you brought
her out and tried to use her as like a I don't know a card in
your campaign for some
This is just echo chamber stuff. You know, they all convinced
themselves that her making two can camp campaign stops with Liz
Cheney
>> like lost her votes and potentially even like and it
gave Trump ammo to paint Harris as the pro-war one. Oh, right.
Was it with Liz Cheney where where Kla Harris said we're going
to have the most lethal military? That wasn't with Liz Cheney
on a on a on a stage, was it? Cuz that would be so horrible.
That would be such a a blunder. It would boggle the mind.
Oh, she didn't do that with Liz Cheney. That is DNC. Oh, that
was her DNC speech. It still was bad. But I thought she did it
with with Liz Cheney by her side. >> Lost her the election.
There's not a single person in this country that did not vote
for Kla Harris because of Liz Cheney. Okay. >> The Democratic
coalition. How about you go to shut the upsville? How about that?
How about you were dead wrong about everything? Kla came out
the gates hot as a >> really Sarah Longwell uh very
endorsed Kla Harris. Sarah Longwell definitely in her own way
in the way that she thought >> like this is this is such
a you want to talk about hiding your power level Hutch. You're
picking actual neocons who just hate Trump because of the anti-democracy
thing and you're going I want these neocons to be happy way more
than somebody like Hassan [__] or any of his camp.
Are you
serious man? Because she endorsed Kla
>> What did What did that endorsement do? What did that
carry? Who did that bring into the coalition?
Anyone? Cuz I can tell you what it did for somebody like Connor.
Counterpoints, right? Didn't Counterpoints refuse to vote because
he didn't think KMA would protect guns.
How are these your reliable voters? How are these the people
you're going to get and keep it your coalition? It makes no sense.
Was helpful. Genuinely tried to get Kla Harris across the finish
line compared with someone like Kyle who did not do that. And
so I just don't understand what gives him the I don't know, man.
Is this compensation?
Is this like psychological compensation going on here? Yeah.
All of these people uh Connor said he would vote for what? JD
Vance over Kla Harris, right? JD Vance over was it Kla Harris
or AOC? I think it was JD Vance over AOC, right?
And yeah, Sarah Longwell here we're seeing apparently said she
would have voted for Rubio over Kamla.
Does he feel guilty? I don't know what this is.
Rubio the guy who is architecting the takeover of Cuba currently
Kolinsky hands down by far when her and Tim Walls same as Sarah
Longwell doing the
hold on
Liz Cheney did more to save this country from Donald Trump than
Kyle
there's no way there's no way I should car crash south dude there's
no way he just said that are you serious
because she said I endorse Kla Harris
that's why because she said I endorse Kla Harris Harris,
all of the pro-comla propaganda Kyle was putting out. All of
it. And apparently just these words, I endorse Kla Harris.
That was all you needed. That was it. Are you serious? Somebody
get this to Kyle Kolinsky. Hutch says Hutch says Neocon, infamous
Neocon, who on one principle alone votes against the Republican
party,
cheated more for Kla Harris to get more votes for Kla Harris
than Kyle Kolinsky did. This is insane. This person is not a
serious political actor at all. What a [__] man.
>> Hands down. By far. When her and Tim Walls were same
with Sarah Longwell doing the rallies and Tim Walls was making
jokes about JD Vance. Uh >> oh, wait. Sorry. It was Liz
Cheney first and then Sarah Longwell, but I I'd heard the Sarah
Longwell part before. I >> having sex with couches and
they were talking about how we're going to ban price gouging
uh for groceries. And they came out hot and aggressive and they
went left. And at that moment, polls came out that had her up
six points on Donald Trump. Then as soon as the Biden people
infiltrated and the never Trumpers infiltrated and what happened
oh they soften the Kyle see this is what Kyle is doing he's Kyle
just weaves Kyle is very much an emotionally driven guy and he
gets things wrong sometimes the Biden people
you could say they infiltrated but Biden's plan to stay in office
Biden's plan to stay and continue with on with his nomination
right sorry not nomination but as the incumbent was to turn to
Bernie Sanders and AOC he tried to do like a more populist pivot
I think You trying to say the Biden people with regards to Kamla?
Like Biden was
Biden's the most populous president you've had in a long time.
Biden was the most like I I think that's crazy to say infiltrated
by the Biden people. Personally, I think that's a little goofy,
right? She stopped talking about the banning of price gouging
on groceries. She started talking about having the most lethal
military in the world. She now I will say some more neoliberal
types did infiltrate. It seems like she wouldn't commit to Lena
Khan, right? I believe she failed to commit to Lena Khan, keeping
her on. She Yeah. moved to talking about the military, increasing
military spending. >> He had on uh you know, she was out
there with Lee Cheney all the time, which by the way netted her
zero voters, probably lost more voters. Like for sake, hello,
this is the Democratic party. Most of us live through the Bush
years and we saw the horrors and we hated the neocon wararmongers
and your brilliant idea was to bring a neocon waronger and say
I'm with these these people who you hate. And so the fact that
she has the nerve to go out there and like she's policing it.
You got HERE YESTERDAY. YOU GOT TO THE coalition yesterday. Are
you kidding me? Okay. We also >> When has when has Kyle
Kolinsky ever been a part of the Democratic Party coalition in
a meaningful way? >> Oh my god, dude.
Again, this guy was doing whippets in the back of a
Volkswagen Beetle while Kyle Klinsky was doing Democratic politics.
I have no idea what he's talking about. Why are you talking about
this? Why are you pretending you were a part of this? You're
not on the team, bro. You're not on the
getting super blasted and hitting 360 nocopes in Call of Duty
while Kyle Klinsky was actually doing political work. And this
guy goes, "When are you a part of the coalition?" >> Has
he ever been a part of He says like >> he says now he would
vote for Joe Mansion in 2028 if he was the in a thought experiment.
But like that's that's a pretty new development. And we'll see
what happens when we get there. Cuz if it's Kla Harris or if
it's Gavin Newsome, I would not comfortably bet any amount of
money that he will endorse either of those two. He says he's
going to, but we'll see.
>> We will see. >> Oh, have this. It's politics says,
and people wonder why some never Trump Republicans are not the
best allies. Listen to Sarah Longwell. She came yesterday to
the Democratic party and maybe she doesn't agree with the majority
of positions of the base like Medicare for all taxing the rich
and decoupling from Israel, but she gets to pick and choose what
people are in the tent. Get the >> she is voicing her opinion
like everybody else is within this. she is an actual like part
of this coalition. >> She's
putting out her opinion that someone else should be deplatformed
and they're going, "Hey, I think you've contributed far less
to this cause over the past 5 to 10 years than Hassan or Kyle
or anyone else and so I don't respect your opinion." That literally
saying you should shut up is also their opinion. If it's all
opinion, then you shouldn't be mad at Kyle. Kyle can say his
opinion too >> in a meaningful way.
She's not I don't think Sarah Longwell is claiming authority
to be able to exile people unilaterally. She's having a debate
with somebody that works for her media company. >> What
is wrong with that? Getting thoroughly embarrassed in it. By
the way, why are you trying to say that that >> I don't
know. I don't know why people are defending Sarah when she got
totally embarrassed in that debate. In that conversation, she's
literally audibly seething into her microphone.
the whole debate. She's audibly seething into her microphone
when Tim goes when Tim says something like, "Well, maybe Israel
could stop blowing kids up. Shouldn't even happen. The out of
here." So, here's another clip that went viral. Here we go. >> Should
he be in the tent or out of the tent? Is a question of like,
"Okay, who is this guy? What does he believe? What does he talk
about on what is a relatively popular streaming site?" And I'll
just give you a flavor of some of >> Here come the smears.
Here come the out of context. >> The smears. She's literally
just reading >> Quotes. Let's get it. >> Things that
pop up from Hassan's >> She actually lies explicitly. She
doesn't even quote the third way article correctly. She actually
gets it wrong and says Hassan stands on all of these things when
he has apologized for some of them or recontextualize some of
them >> that I have seen and that I think are quite quite
terrible. So America deserved 911, dude. >> Uh yeah, that's
a smear. Is he about to Hang on. What is Kyle about to say right
now? Oh dear. >> It's the CIA concept of blowback is what
he's talking about. No, >> no, that's not what blowback
means. Blowback is not a moral condemnation of the United States.
Blowback is just a cause and effect kind of situation. That's
a
>> What do you think deserves means? You
holy [__]
Wait, is that what he's going Maybe that's what he's going to
argue. Hold on. Maybe that's what he's going to argue is when
you say deserving, it's like America through its actions deserves
something some retribution.
I I hope that's what he's going to argue. Cuz if he doesn't argue
that, he's lost it. It's not a moral condemnation of the United
States. You deserve something bad. I believe that's saying you've
done something bad. You deserve karma. you deserve like something
to I don't know set the scales
pack. >> Appealing to blowback or talking about the concept
of blowback is not the same thing as saying that you know 3,000
Americans deserve to be >> but he's explicitly said that's
not what he means. He is he is describing that America has done
things that have guaranteed and say that that America deserves
some retribution for this. He's not saying those individuals
deserve to die. I'm sure he would have loved to see that happen
in a different way. Right. brutally murdered
uh 25 years ago. It's not the same thing. It's not the same thing.
Once you add the Yeah, once you add the word >> I think
Hutch is arguing what I'm arguing though. >> He wasn't
like, you know, Bin Laden did like, you know, military targets.
>> He wasn't attacking the military. He just murdered 3,000
civilians. That's that's what happened that day. And
>> yeah, but you under do we not understand that what's
going on there? Is he saying for if he had said America deserves
to, you know, feel 1 1,000th the pain, 1/100th the pain
that some of these Middle Eastern countries have felt, would
would you accept that? Would that be enough? Cuz like that's
basically what the suggestion is, right? Like I don't want the
same thing, but like you should you should understand what this
pain feels like. Not saying he wants civilians killed. It's just
like dude, you you have brought this upon yourself. You've you've
pulled out you've uh what do you call it? You've taken on some
>> Said that you know America deserved >> No, he's
not uh pro- al-Qaeda, pro Osama bin Laden, pro terrorist attack
against civilians in the United States. And the only reason why
>> What do you mean? I don't when you say someone deserved
something I mean that seems pretty pro to me. I don't I don't
know if he's generally pro- al-Qaeda or Osama bin Laden, but
if you say that America deserved 9/11, that seems pretty pro,
you know. >> Did Japan deserve the the nuclear bombs? I
mean that like I'm just telling you that's a tough question.
That is not an immediate no question. They don't deserve they
didn't deserve the bombs at all. That's that's not an easy question.
That's the same thing when you say America deserves 911. It's
not the same. It's it's difficult, right?
It's difficult to understand. It's difficult to put into words.
It's like I don't want civilians killed, but these people have
targeted civilians. They've done like a whole bunch of war crimes
around the world. What do they deserve for that? What what have
they taken on karmically?
I don't know. It's complicated. >> Laden, pro-terrorist
attack against civilians in the United States. And the only reason
why what do you mean? I >> you know if you're right, do
you think that's good optics for your party? No. That's why I
say that's why I think you should apologize and explain what
you were trying to do, which I think Hassan did. So I don't even
know. Like I don't know why you would mention this without also
mentioning the apology and him saying this is what I meant. Personally,
when you when you after he apologized and said, "I shouldn't
have said it that way. Here's what I meant." I think if you don't
include that in the context, you're being disingenuous, and that's
what makes it a smear. >> When you say someone deserved
something, I mean, that seems pretty pro to me. I don't I don't
know if he's generally pro al-Qaeda or Osama bin Laden, but if
you say that America deserved 9/11, that seems pretty pro. You
know, >> you're implying that's the case is because you're
an Islamophobic hag. His name is Hassan,
>> dude. Hag. Hag. He's calling this a hag. Let's go, Kyle.
Picking up the lingo. The kids
>> That seems pretty pro. You know, >> you're implying
that's the case is because you're an Islamophobic hag. His name
is
>> Kyle started to use. >> What is I'm sorry, what?
How did that get thrown into your >> So you think you can
get away with a quick one by pretending he's proter terrorism?
No. In fact, on his show, he talks out against terrorism daily.
Okay. >> Okay. There's a little copy. This is a little
kopi from Kyle. This was a little >> That's news to me.
Excuse me. When has a son ever had a broad like anti-terrorism
>> Hey, this is why he covers the genocide in Gaza where
they're murking civilians on a daily basis cuz he's anti-terrorism.
He doesn't want any >> Somebody queued up that clip of
him saying we, you know, our Hezbollah are terrorists. But yeah,
you know, I generally don't have a problem with them, right?
harm to be done to any civilians and the fact
>> um yeah I
unfortunately
given the past like three months
maybe a year given the past year I'm unfortunately started to
come to understand what Assan meant there
I I'm sorry
I'm sorry
>> what I said about conservatives and
>> I can pull up the clip again of the C4 lining the houses.
I can pull that up for us.
And then blowing up the houses in a line. I can pull that up.
>> We're having a conversation. So, uh, you said America
deserved 9/11. Did you mean
>> Yeah.
Oops. That's uh, that is not the context. That is not the context
I was expecting. Thank you, though. >> I'm living up to
what I said about conservative and progress. >> Damn.
I do think he actually apologizes there. fact that you you didn't
realize. >> Rate his hairline. Um it looks like he has
some male pattern baldness emerging here. He's doing kind of
like a I was doing this a little bit
back when I had hair where you kind of use this use some of the
hair on the side and flip it up like that to cover up the the
male pattern baldness here. I think he pulls it off better than
I did back then. He's referring to the CIA concept of blowback.
>> Can you He's not, by the way. That's not what he's saying.
He's not talking about blowback. He's saying like it was a morally
justified thing to do. Um, >> can you hide male pattern
baldness
>> if you bleach >> your hair blonde?
>> I see that and make about you and nothing about him.
Jesus Christ. >> On China, he says focus on the social
repression or the civil liberties or not even civil liberties
necessarily, but free speech and things like that. But in terms
of good governance, there's a lot we can learn from the way they
perform out there. At least >> uh that's just literally
factually correct. That's like not even arguable. That's not
even debatable. We have all these beautiful high-speed trains
where they built out cuz they're a uni party. They're a uni party
who ban any and
why are you why are you like content with the statement >> political
opposite didn't by the way doesn't hold on I need to listen to
that >> necessarily free speech and things like that but
in terms of good governance there's a lot we can learn >> yeah
so the first part is the uni party part so Hutch so Hassan even
in the quote Sarah's reading contextualizes right like it literally
is saying I understand that there's a dictatorship at all this
but they get some stuff the way they perform out there at least.
>> Uh that's just literally factually correct. That's like
not even arguable. That's not even debatable. They have all these
beautiful high-speed trains where they built out cuz they're
a uni party. They're a uni party who ban any political opposition
that poses any actual kind of threat to them whatsoever. They're
a uni party. I mean, I agree. I mean, like, are you making the
case for abundance? Like, maybe I >> All of the infrastructure
since like 2008 until today. It's a [__] modern marvel
of engineering. It's phenomenal. That's the [__]
he's talking about. Hey, look at the highspeed trains. Look at
the state-of-the-art airports. Look at how their mid-level cities
now mog the [__] out of our [__] top
level cities. That's what he's talking about. You're trying to
make some benal factual observation like controversial and unacceptable.
This is the sort of cancel >> Are you is he even going
to reference at all
the point about like civil rights? I mean, did you hear what
she said? I mean, she's here >> and things like that. But
in hyper >> him Jesus Christ. >> Wait, does Hutch
understand that
>> China? He says we hyper focus on the social repression
or the civil liberties or not even civil liberties necessarily
but free speech and things like that. But in terms of good governance
there's >> he just leaprogs past that point like just violating
people's civil liberties or just any kind like a lack of civil
liberties you know >> but but Hassan didn't Kyle maybe
Kyle did but Hassan didn't Hassan literally says I understand
those problems but also China does these things well >> you're
just not free to just speak openly about them. >> We can
learn from the way they perform out there at least. >> Uh
that's just literally fact here we >> and he has a lot
of fairy pro. No, he just didn't didn't touch that at all. >> Uh
uh takes
he's able to call a spade a spade. Don't you know we're supposed
to shut our brains off and say and everything ever about China
is evil and wrong and bad. >> There's one >> I mean
just give me one criticism of China, Kyle. I mean just off the
top of your head, would you be able to >> he was a little
bit taken out of >> Why? Why would he say that? Do you
think Kyle has no criticism? Do you think Kyle likes free speech
or hates free speech? You think that wouldn't be a criticism
he has? Like the the line that's being drawn here is Hutch expects
when somebody's making a point that he doesn't like, he wants
them to caveat that point in every possible way. Okay, Kyle's
never going to do that. That's
That is always content. And and Hutch is sitting here like Randall
from recess with his notepad out. He's like, "I noticed you didn't
criticize China when you said something was good about them.
That'll be a fine later."
Hey, nerd. Shut the up. Nobody cares. He's He's vibing. He's
rolling. He's
This is what content is, man. I know you don't recognize it.
I know it's hard to recognize, but he's not going to sit here
and do every single throw clear every single time he says something
that could possibly mean he supports somebody else.
Okay. Yeah. China gets really cool stuff built.
Um, you forgot to add that they abuse human rights and they're
like a uni party. They're an authoritarian dictatorship and they
come from a communist regime. Yeah, that's not relevant to my
point right now.
Well, I think that you're kind of misleading your audience and
thinking them they're making them think that China's really cool.
Yeah, I don't care. I don't care.
China's probably cool more cool than they think.
Although, I will say China's Navy is still embarrassing. All
you senophiles in my chat, China's China's military, Chinese
n China's n China's navy both embarrassing. Both a total joke.
Bunch of fishing boats. Okay, shut up. >> Out of context.
But he says doesn't matter what the happened on OCTOBER 7TH.
>> WHEN YOU admit before you do the smear that Well, THIS
ONE'S OUT OF CONTEXT.
>> HOW DID YOU let those words come out of your mouth?
I think her point was he phrased what he had to say in
a very problematic way. Like there's a way to say that even if
atrocities took place on October 7th, it doesn't just >> and
Hutch can't imagine Hutch could never imagine collaborating with
and not pointing out somebody saying something problematic. He
could never imagine could never imagine it.
Absolutely >> Why the way that Israel has conducted their
like military campaign, but the way he said it was so loaded.
It was so
>> Oh my days. How did you let that escape your mouth?
Well, he was in the in the context of the clip. He's literally
saying, "Don't try to deny violence on October 7th." That's what
he's telling the person that's talking to him. >> That
doesn't change the dynamic for me even this much. So, that's
the other part of this problem that many people contend with.
Like, the Palestinian Palestinian resistance is not perfect.
They're not like so good. Uh they have magical bullets. I don't
know what that mean. He says Hamas is 1,000 times better than
Israel. >> Literally, he's talking about math. How many
people died on October 7th? Like what? 2,000. And >> I
mean, there was a big problem with that, which is that, you know,
Hassan definitely has gone out of his way to deny violence on
October 7th. But, okay. on how many you're getting in Gaza? >> I'm
sorry. This is the one thing I need to get better at this or
I used to need to get better at this. I think the Israel issue
is teaching me how to do this that it's like watching people
try to reframe on stupid.
Okay. Absolute just dumb.
Well, you know, Hassan denies violence. Here's the problem.
Why should I believe that you care about violence in the Middle
East when you don't care about all the other things? You don't
talk about any of the other things they do in the Middle East.
talk about I need you to start disavowing the things Israel is
doing and saying that they're disgusting and you will support
anybody who will restrict or remove all funding to Israel immediately.
If you say that I'll go, "Yeah, Hassan was a little up about
this violence on October 7th." He might have even denied it in
some cases when he shouldn't have. Okay, I'll give you that.
I'll I'll tell you Hassan denied on October 7th. Hassan denied
the He's a monster. I'll give you all of that. If you just go
through all the things Israel's been doing since and you talk
about them and you say that they're disgusting, they move you
in a way that nothing else on the global stage moves you and
we're ready to totally cut funding to Israel. That would be awesome.
But you don't actually care. You don't care about any of these
things. You just like to have thought termination and go Hassan
denied.
That's what you want. Cuz we're about to get rolling on the laundry
list of things about Israel.
And you're like, well, Hassan denied. Yeah, I I literally don't
care in in in
proportion to the things Israel has done, right?
If you want to make me believe that you care about Hassan doing
that,
then talk about the Israel's done cuz it's orders of magnitude
worse.
70,000 80,000. In reality, I think it's like at least 200,000,
by the way, for the record. That's what I think is at least 200,000.
But let's go with the low number like 70,000. It's a mathematical
reality that 70,000 innocent people being murdered by the Israeli
government is a much higher number than about 2,000 being killed
by Hamas on October 7TH. THAT'S THE POINT. ARE YOU NOW GOING
TO PROCEED TO ARGUE AGAINST MATH? Is that what you're going to
do? Please try. Let me see how that works out for you. >> On
Hezbollah, he said overall, let's >> I mean, we don't judge
the morality of this group versus that group based on death count.
You know, >> why not?
>> We base it on their words instead of the outcome of
their actions. That's what we do. that because these people said
like
if you if you shoot somebody in the head and say the heart, you're
a monster. But if you put a blindfold on and then shoot somebody
in the head, you're not a
>> Okay. I don't you understand that? Like especially once
somebody's put that blindfold on and shot 70,000 to possibly,
if Kyle's estimate is true, 200,000 people, I go, "Oh, I actually
think you're a monster anyway. regardless of what you said. I
actually don't care what you said anymore
because what you said seems to not correspond to reality ever.
>> Oh, you know, we're the most moral army. We're trying
to just do the right thing. And then I watch an entire an entire
like well, what we should call it state just wiped off the map.
And now I'm watching it happen in Lebanon again. And I go, hey,
it's almost starting to seem like this might be intentional.
Like you might be doing this intentionally.
Hey, maybe the things you say, the intent, so to speak, is not
judgable because you just lie about your intent. You just lie
all the time. You're a liar. >> We just don't. That's not
how we do these things. >> My favorite flag, Hezbollah,
look it up. I'm not even kidding. >> Which is not to run
defense for Israel because I'm not that that's not the point.
But >> you are running defense for Israel. That's what
that was. That was you running defense for Israel because you're
not willing to admit what I just said. That Israel as a country
is a lying son of a [__]
Okay. If it were a person, it would be a
totally degenerate
uh what's the word?
Pathological liar. Everything. All lies all the time. That state
does nothing but lie about their intentions. They will never
actually hold on. Asmin Gold and Israel actually aligned on this
totally. Okay, I I forgot that I had this Asminy clip. This Asminy
clip is perfectly It perfectly describes what Israel does. Right
here it is. >> A slur now? I mean, it should be. I'll tell
you that. Some you have to stand on principle which is why you're
correct. Well, the thing is that
I don't have principles goals. >> Oh, sorry. I cut him
off. This is BB Netanyahu right here. >> I don't have principles.
I have goals. And those goals are informed by certain principles.
But fundamentally, if the principle and the goal don't align.
The goal supersedes the principle. That's the way I do. That's
the way I look at things because the outcome is really what matters.
And anybody who doesn't have that viewpoint, I think is very
dangerous to have in a leadership role because if you have that
viewpoint and you're making decisions, you can do what needs
to be done versus a person that wants to make decisions based
off of ideology. Sometimes you're making decisions for a world
that you want to be real, hoping to manifest it, but the reality
is that people still have to suffer the consequences from it
in the
This is absolutely but this is like
the things he said are stupid regardless. It's like about the
goal and if the goal can be accomplished through just lying to
people. Yeah, absolutely we're going to lie. What? Of course
we're going to lie. Why wouldn't we lie? Of course we're going
to lie. That's what's going on here. So when you hear them telling
you things, understand that they will tell you anything to achieve
a goal. The the biggest problem as I see it with a lot of the
analysis from people like Kyle and Hassan is they just don't
make any space for how profoundly bad Hamas is and how Hamas
um again just orders of magnitude less bad than Israel.
>> And when when you have to keep doing this throat clear
about how bad Hamas is, you look insane. Right now there are
400 people watching at least maybe 450
close maybe possibly 500 people watching right now who all think
you're insane for saying this
>> every single time
I ultimately
>> there's only so long and I I said this by the way I'll
always point this out
uh Lyken came on my stream debated like a pro-Israeli DJer and
the pro-Israeli DJ made this argument that Hutch is about to
make. Well, actually, principally they're for genocide and principally
like if they could if they could they would kill everybody. And
I said, what's the number where suddenly like you don't think
the principles are all that different? What is the number, the
Hitler number where you think Israel is really not all that different
than the Nazis? There has to be a number because you can't just
say, well, they don't say they want to genocide them, so it's
never genocide. Well, they never say they want to kill these
people, so it's never a problem. What's the number? I put that
at 10,000. Some other people put it lower. Some other people
put it way higher. Regardless, pretty much everybody who picked
a number around November of 2023
has had their number exceeded massively.
So, the whole idea of like what the intent is and oh well, their
statements beforehand, I don't care. Every single thing Israel's
done shows that they have genocidal intent towards these people.
Not just the Palestinians,
but like Lebanese Muslims, too. Obviously,
Iranians,
tons. And again, you will never ever be get me to take you seriously
if you try to refocus the the conversation to Hamas or the rhetoric
or the reasons they do things. I don't care.
I will never be made to care again. >> Um
have been tremendously
unless unless Hamas somehow figures out a way to get close to
Israel's numbers. If they do something like that and they get
close to Israel's numbers, then I would have a ton of condemnation,
right?
But you I'm going to I'm going to start referring this. They
have to get to at least half an Israel of evil. If they can't
get to half an Israel of evil, then I'm not really interested
in hearing it. Destructive for the Palestinian people that they
govern in Gaza. There's just not. They think that any conversation
about that is a distraction against or distraction from the only
conversation that should be having. They keep doing this thing
where like they >> It is. It is because it's orders of
magnitude different. This is like like could you imagine if I
was talking about the Holocaust and I then talked about like
I was like, "Oh yeah, the Holocaust is really similar to like
this Sandy Hook shooting that happened in America." It's basically
like the same thing.
Could you understand how offensive that would be to somebody
who was and had survived the Holocaust?
Yeah. It's kind of like the school shooting. The guy came in,
he just wanted to kill everybody. It's basically the same
Oh, is it? Because it seems orders of magnitude different. Treat
things like they're mutually exclusive. You know, like because
Donald Trump is doing this really bad stuff in this country,
that means you shouldn't spend, I guess, any time having a conversation
about Hassan. The real problem these people all have
anti-semmites pointed to Israel having too much influence in
government and they pointed to Israel basic like anti-semmites
pointed to Israel lying. Okay. They sorry anti-semmites pointed
to Israel lying a lot and they pointed to Israel having too much
influence in American government.
Both of those things have come to be found true
obviously true.
And unfortunately everybody rather than admit oh you know even
though it's not a vindication of their their ethos of their of
their method their logic
they were right on this broken clock write it twice a day or
whatever right but honestly they will argue well if we say that
they're right then the anti-semites win and so I don't know how
to talk about this like dude are you
are you serious this is rough man this is really rough to watch
like I'm sorry They do have too much influence. They do lie to
everybody so long as it fits their goals.
>> And because of what Israel has weird to complain about
Israel influence and not Russian influence. What do you mean
by Russian influence?
And is it anywhere near what Israel Israeli influence is? Again,
is it like I would condemn any influence Russia has over the
president. Like if they if they have blackmail or however they
move Trump, you know, Trump seems to be very favorable to Russia.
I don't like it. I just can't identify the Russian influence
very easily like I can the Israeli influence. So if you can point
me to anything that's as obvious, right? Because I see the US
supporting Ukraine, giving weapons to Ukraine. I see the US in
a totally in a way that doesn't serve any of its interests going
to war with and destroying the world economy for Israel. Where
can we see the this level of disconnect between what's in the
US's interest and their policy towards a given region or country?
like this level of disconnect from like, oh, the US is with no
danger to itself going to actually obliterate the world economy
to guarantee the the security of Israel.
Where do we see that level of disconnect? If you could point
me to that, I would be happy to go into it cuz I would love to
know about that. That seems like a really important thing to
talk about. Yeah, you just said something. You literally totally
lost the argument, Galugi. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Tenant, AFD,
Hungary, Piers.
Piers. You think Piers Morgan is Russian influenced? None of
that has any effect over the United States.
Like, sorry, it has a totally negligible effect on the United
States.
Literally, we're about to read an article that is explaining
how the prime minister of of Israel gave bad intelligence to
the United States and convinced them that they could win a war
almost immediately with America. Sorry, with uh Iran. I literally
don't care about anything that's not on this level or within
give me something that's within two orders of magnitude this
level.
If there's anything like that, I will go hard. I will I will
dig that up. I'll go into it. Did BB know the intelligence was
bad? Was he actively lying? There are indications that he obviously
knew the intelligence was bad.
Msad literally had the conventional MSAD and CIA wisdom was there's
no way to do a coup in Iran. Nobody was even putting efforts
towards it at all on any level until like 2024 and then after
a year and a half of work they come they come to Trump and go
yeah we could totally coup this country. So do you believe they
really thought that or do you think that for some reason they
just thought they could fool somebody running who who was about
to win an election? I don't know about the JD Orban thing. I
don't I'm not looking at it right now.
Again the insane sweep over Israel is what what actually like
drives me insane right now. the insane sweep over the obliteration
of the world economy. I'm gonna have to suffer through the raised
prices. You're going to have to suffer through the raised prices.
JD and Victor Orban meeting and each other in the ass. I'm assuming
that's like the weirdest thing they could do. I literally don't
care. I don't know what that changes. I super don't give a
I I literally don't care at all. Yeah. Is done post October 7th.
You shouldn't have any conversation about like Hamas and how
they've contributed to this conflict and this violence in their
own way. And if you're missing that entirely from your analysis,
then I don't think you're painting like the full picture of how
they got to that point. >> Okay. Can we talk about how
basically like any entertaining of like this is the argument
people make when they want to talk about NATO,
making overtures to Ukraine and how that caused the Russian war,
right? If you're not willing to talk about any how entertaining
overtures from NATO, talking about NATO caused the Russo Ukrainian
war, the current Russo Ukrainian conflict, then you're sweeping
Well, actually,
even if overtures were made, it's like orders of magnitude less
bad than invading another country and killing a ton of people.
So, I'm not going to talk about that. I'm going to talk about
the war and the totally unjustified illegal invasion. How about
that? People can't even apply the principles they claim to have
to other situations. And it's it just shows >> a dope flag.
It's got an AK on it and a >> And Tim Miller is laughing.
Why? Because when you talk about something like this, it's literally
just how a flag looks. That's a joke. >> I think Tim Miller
is laughing like oh with her, dude. If you think if you think
meeting with Victor Orban is within the top 50 reasons that JD
Vance is killing liberal democracy, you're out of your mind.
I literally don't care about Victor Orban.
J Vance is going to kill American democracy for Americans.
Getting paid by Americans to kill liberal democracy in America.
The domestic issue is the problem there. I don't think Tim Miller
is being dismissive of that. I think Tim Miller that was him
laughing like, "Okay, that's kind of crazy." He's not laughing
at her. You think Tim Miller would be just like poo poo, you
know, glazing Hezbollah, then I don't think you know much about
Tim Miller. Joke. Okay. And that's why >> he is laughing
at her. She's histrionic.
He is laughing at her. He was laughing at her and taking her
not seriously the entire time. >> Tim Miller is laughing
again. What? >> I don't think that's why he's laughing.
>> Like they're trying so hard and they're getting absolutely
nothing. And by the way, don't take Assan's word for it. There
was an article that came out the Telegraph which they deleted
because it got a little too close to the truth. And in that article,
they spoke to Christians in Lebanon who were like, "Oh, yeah,
we got no problem with Hezblah. They protect us from the psychotic
Israelis." THEY THOUGHT THEY WOULD THEY THOUGHT, "WE'RE GOING
TO GO TALK to the Christians, face closed, guys, uh, in in Lebanon,
and they're all going to say Hezblah is evil and wrong, and they're
bad." And they're >> I mean, why does why does the IDF
call every house in Christian towns and let them know if you
if you take in any Shia Muslims, we will bomb your house? WHY?
HOW IS THAT NOT EVIL? If you take in your neighbors, if you take
in any of your neighbors, we'll kill you and your family. We'll
blow your house up.
Is that not psychotic? How's that not psychotic? They're terrorists
and they're and they're this and they're that. And they were
like, "Oh, no. They uh they actually protect us from the Israelis
and they do Christmas celebrations and they put up a Christmas
tree and they all they're all very nice to us."
>> Okay, you know what? I had a negative opinion of Hezbollah,
but all that's changed now. Like again, like I know that the
sort of the whole thing
>> I know Hutch is willing to How can you watch the same
trick happen to you? Hutch is sitting at like some threecard
Monty out in the in New York City. Okay. Some street hustler
running three-card Monty and Hutch is about to lose his mortgage
to this guy. He just keeps betting and betting and betting on
the same thing and he keeps getting hustled and hustled and hustled.
Guys,
Kyle's like, "These civilians are really up and they like they
don't hate Hezbollah and they love their their Shia neighbors.
They're they're just people to them." Um, yeah. Well, have you
considered that there's like a militant around like 60 of those
people and that's why we have to blow up an apartment block?
No, I didn't consider that. That sounds insane. That sounds like
something I would never sanction. That sounds absurd. Are you
out of your mind?
That's like the reality of the situation. That's how these these
things are being when you go, but what about Hezbollah? But what
about Hamas? That's how it's being used to destroy multiple populations
entire capacity to enjoy their lives ever. And you think that
because you call them, you go, "Hey, if you stay in that house,
you're going to die. You're a moral person." You're not. You're
a piece of [__] About being a right-winger is that
you're a idiot and you're incredibly ignorant about the world.
But this is really something. You think you're in the democratic
tent and this is how you talk. You think you're in the democratic
tent? Please I think most people in the Democratic tent are opposed
to Hezbollah and Hamas and condemn what happened on October 7th.
It's so lazy. It's so lazy. It's so insanely lazy. I did all
of these throat clears. I condemned all of these things. And
if you don't understand that now at this point in time when you
sit when you sit on these things and you focus on them and you
try to constantly what about with them you are actually if you
knew the Holocaust was happening just a little a little analogy
if you knew the Holocaust was happening
except you thought it was happening to like terrorists okay and
you go well I know you guys want to go like strike Germany I
know you guys want to stop funding Germany but like I just don't
know like there there are terrorists there and I don't really
think They're that evil. Like, why can't you guys condemn the
terrorism? Like, terrorism,
and you keep upholding the same status quo over and over and
over again while people are dying, they're having their lives
you are you are abetting something
If the situation was cold, if nothing was happening, I would
say we could have this conversation. You could what about with
Hamas all you like. Okay? If this was October of 2022, you could
what about with Hamas all you like and I'll have that conversation
with you all day. But terrible things are happening and you are
constantly obiscating. You are constantly slowing down the conversation.
Please do not do that. Will you condemn the Warsaw uprising?
Yes, exactly. I've I've said this on stream before. Yes. Do you
condemn the Warsaw uprising? Do you condemn it?
What? Why?
What? That seems really stupid.
Anyway, with $5 live and learn influence reaching some mainstream
figures flowchart posted by Matthew opposed to Hezbollah and
Hamas and condemn what happened on October 7th. Piler with $5
live and learn influence reaching some mainstream figures. Flowchart
posted by Matthew Eiglacius. Well, I didn't come up with the
flowchart. I'd love to take credit for that. I don't know who
came up with that first, but I see it every I mean I talk about
flowchart a lot. I'm looking at his feed. Where are you see Oh,
there it is. Boom.
I would love to take credit for this chart because it's so accurate.
It so accurately describes how a lot of people's brains work.
And there's a lot of that going on today on Twitter, by the way.
If you just kind of glance >> on Dan Crunch losing an eye
in Afghanistan. What the is wrong with this dude. I also dislike
Dan Crunch. >> Assan also condemned October 7th. Wait,
I'm sorry. When did he ever do just like no caveat, just an unequivocal
condemnation. The closest I ever saw him get to doing that was
when he went on Piers Morgan and Piers Morgan asked him like,
"Do you condemn what happened on October 7th?" And he said yes.
But then but but and then he added like 10 qualifiers to it.
That's the only time I've ever seen him come close to condemning
October 7th. The most that he can muster on October 7th on the
day that the bodies were piling up. >> So he condemned
it.
>> So it's just categorically wrong for you to say he didn't
condemn it. >> He condemned the bad part. >> Now
I understand why he's trying to say like I'm never going to condemn
an uprising from people who are in this like state of oppression.
I'm never going to condemn that fully. I understand why he says
that. And unfortunately, we've gotten a very very very obvious
and clear, you know, vision view into the way Israelis see these
people, okay? What they're going to do the second they think
they can.
I dude, it's I just don't understand how you could run the October
like the December 2023 to January 2020, sorry, January 2025 talking
points for this. How How can you run these talking points still?
Aren't you embarrassed?
Like, don't you feel inhuman running these talking points
given the the total the massive discrepancy in casualties and
the multiple other fronts that Israel started conflicts on?
Was that no resistance is perfect? I'm paraphrasing. He said
something like
If you can find me a single clip of him saying, "Why is that
a problem for you?" Why is that a problem for you?
By the way, just just to make it clear for everybody, does everybody
know why Hassan says no resistance is perfect and I want to remind
everybody no resistance is perfect and these people have been
oppressed. Do you think that's him sweeping for Hamas or do you
think that's him knowing in the back of his head that these evil
Israeli about to roll through there and genocide that entire
place? Which one? Which one do you think it is, Hutch? cuz I
know that's why everybody was focused on atrocity and trying
to downplay what was going on because they thought in the in
their heart of hearts they thought that was going to be used
to justify any crime done to the Palestinians. And what happened?
It was used to justify every crime done to the Palestinians.
And you're borderline doing it now.
So, how about you open your ears up and go relisten to those
clips, rewatch what happened in history, okay, the past two years,
and come back to us with an updated opinion cuz holy, this is
that what Hamas did on October 7th, the attack that they carried
out was completely unacceptable.
Then I am all ears. Just show me that clip, please. I would love
to see that. I would love to be wrong about this. >> By
the way, I have no problem. Like, I could say killing civilians
is wrong. What Hamas did was wrong. going after civilians was
wrong. But
I have no issue with the people who would who would try to caveat
and say, "But I want you to understand that these people's point
of view, the lives they've had, the the way they were raised,
the thing they they the things they lived through, I understand
everybody doing that now." And I think those people were obviously
correct. And you refusing to admit that or refusing to like capitulate
on that at all is embarrassing. And everybody who's doing that
is embarrassing. >> He doesn't do that. He he treats what
Hamas did as
the inevitable outcome of what he describes as decades of aparthide.
>> He said by the way, >> I probably have this VOD
somewhere. I probably have the VOD of me having this conversation
with people on my stream in 2024, like January 2024 or November,
December 2023. I almost certainly have this VOD saved somewhere
of me explicitly talking this exact same topic saying okay like
you can make these arguments but if we if we end up going through
this like cuz I made the atrocity argument at the time that they're
worried about this being used to justify any crimes done and
then we watch all the crimes be done
which is like I don't know how you don't admit you're wrongable
like what did you expect was going to happen and then they make
these like perverse comparisons to the Warsaw ghetto uprising
as though that was in any way comparable to what happened on
October 7th. Just arbitrarily like murdering families on the
Kibitim and murdering people at a rave like they're Who did the
Wait, who did the Who did they murder in the Warsaw Ghetto uprising?
They just murder
Oh, I I say wait,
do you condemn? Yeah, I did do that. But it's just it's funny
to me. By the way, if they had killed German families, let's
say they had killed German families, would that have been wrong?
Would that have been like totally? And hold on, the real question
is, what would that have justified
as retribution to those people?
What would be okay
if those people from the Warsaw ghetto did that? Given the conditions
they were living in, given what they had to look forward to,
what crimes could you justify against them? And you could say
you wouldn't justify anything, but then once you dive into the
future and you see that they were erased and you go, "Well, but
they did kill families." Well, do you disavow them killing families?
When you know that they got
you start to look monstrous. You start to look like a total piece
of [__]
I just would warn these people against doing this. Like, just
don't do it. You look insane. Do what everybody else does. Be
super vague. Cuz as bad as Arerite looks going, I don't like
what's happening at Gaza. Benj Yahoo is not a good guy.
As bad as she looks doing that whole minstrel show, okay, this
looks
Don't try to get specific and and and pinpoint in and just argue
the same points that you were arguing two years ago. It's it's
demonic. There's no equivalent to that in the Warsaw Ghetto >> But
I would not say this. Didn't he go to war and like literally
lose his eye because of some mujaheden, a brave soldier his eyehole
WITH
ALL RIGHT, Y'ALL. NEW KAOU, you're That is That is the only reaction
to that. I can't believe she read it. Even Tim laughed. Even
Tim laughed hard at the Tim. Like, bro,
>> allowed to say whatever the you want to say to joke
about how evil Republican politicians are. There are >> You
can I mean, you're technically free to say these kinds of things,
but I'm just going to guess that most normies are going to be
turned off by that language. like massively turned off even if
they don't like Dan. Donald Trump won the popular vote. Donald
Trump won the popular vote. Donald Trump won the popular vote.
Donald Trump won the popular vote.
Donald Trump won the popular vote. Donald Trump won the popular
vote. Donald Trump won the popular vote. Donald Trump won the
popular vote. And that's for political figures. Not even for
just broadly funny people. Have you ever heard of a comedian
before?
Holy [__] This guy is out of his mind. Oh, you gota
be you won't be shocked. You might be shocked. Normies are turned
off. Who? Where? What the [__] are you talking about?
Worst political instincts in the game. What political instincts?
This guy has
This guy has the survival instincts of like a blind paralyzed
thawn. Okay, imagine if Bambi could never pull itself up when
it was on the ice when Bambi's legs go out, but his legs were
just always given out. Okay, that's Hutch's survival instinct,
right? That's Hutch's survival, you know, capability.
Nothing. He's just like free a free meal for some predator walking
through the woods. Krenshaw,
I I would guess like 80 to 90% of the country are going to be
like massively turned off by that kind of language. >> Literally
no lines when joking about how evil Republican politicians are.
And >> I don't agree. I think that there are lines. I don't
I don't think that the Republicans being bad means that you are
not beholden to any kind of moral standards. That's kind of crazy.
>> Okay. I don't know why Hutch I don't know why Kyle said
no lines. There probably are lines, but they're prabatic ones.
There's probably I don't know if there are moral lines there,
right? Wait, what did I just miss? >> 80 to 90% of the
country are going to be like massively turned off by that. >> Oh,
I didn't I didn't even hear that. I was not listening to him.
I was thinking of something else. Holy [__] 80 to
90% of Dude, what what are you talking about? That's like That's
probably Hassan's most appealing clip, bro. Who's the most mass
appeal person on Instagram? Good evening, everyone. It's It's
April 7th, Tuesday night. Welcome to America First. I'm your
host, Nicholas J. Fuentes, we've got a great show for you tonight.
That's who the That's the guy That's the number one Instagram
res guy. That's the guy who's funny and everybody likes. I would
guess 80 to 90% of the country are going to be like massively
turned off by that kind of language. >> Literally no lines
when joking about how evil Republican politicians are. And >> I
don't agree. I think that there are lines. I don't I don't think
that the Republicans being bad means that you are not beholden
to any kind of moral standards. That's kind of crazy. >> If
you have a problem with it, there's this little thing called
free speech that I'm going to introduce you to. And by the way,
as you're about to see here, Tim Miller's >> I mean, what
about doesn't she have free speech? Hello. Hello. Doesn't she
have free speech to you watch the super chats but not the monologue?
I don't really watch I've I haven't watched like a full show
since I was a Destiny viewer.
I do watch highlights though. Sometimes I'll watch like the clip
if it comes up in my feed. I don't know what happened. I fell
out of the I fell out of the algo for the Fentes clips. I don't
know what happened. It just doesn't get fed to me anymore. So
I'd have to go look it up or people could link it but people
don't even link them anymore. Unlucky generational run is ended.
>> Voice her complaints about Hassan. How come the standard
does not apply to her laughing at this one as well? >> Because
of some mujaheden a brave soldier his eyehole with their on Israel
being full of inbredads. >> This is supposed to make people
not like him. This made people not like them. Oh my god.
I used to think that talks about like echo chambers were overblown
but like they are real. Oh my god. >> This next one too.
This is another sad attempt that I got. Are you ready? >> You
are left with a country that is patched to the gills with the
most imbreed, uneducated, ultra nationalist, ratted, heredi population
on Russia's >> Okay, so he's talking about the ultraorththodox,
right? This is another Kyle rule. Sorry if this one offends people
out there. You are allowed to joke around about how stupid and
evil every single fundamentalist religious group is. No, you're
not going to push us into the corner. You're not allowed to say
it. I will say whatever the I want about
Okay, I hope he understands that a lot of the stuff he decries
is Islamophobic for Kyle here. A lot of the stuff he decries
is llomophobic is making fun of extremists. No, like not all
of it. Sometimes they will call it out, but if he's going to
say, "Oh, you could say whatever you want about religious extremists."
Okay, I'll hold you to it. >> Fundamentalist Christians
and fundamentalist Muslims and fundamentalist fundamentalist
>> point that out or >> do we have any clips of him
talking about fundamentalist Muslims >> are weird, dog?
They're weird. They're >> I maybe I'm not being faired
up. They're >> No, I think that's fair. Funny. They smell.
There's a whole lot of all the fundamentalists of all the different
religions are creepy. You know it. I know it. Everybody knows
it. I'm secular, bro. I'm secular. People can live. How? Wait,
he might he might do this. Hold on. He might do this. Kyle has
always been Yeah, Kyle's always been a Reddit atheist. I forgot
about that. The channel name is secular talk. I totally forgot.
Kyle would definitely talk all fundamental religious people.
For sure. For sure. For sure. For sure. I totally forgot. Dude,
I just watched his first video the other day.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah, sure. Porter Beller,
when you try to paint somebody, it's like, could you imagine
if you tried to paint if you started talking about how Ben Shapiro
was like a dangerous like heredi person or something like dangerous
ultraorththodox Jew and started talking about or ultra Jews that
way. Although Ben is pretty crazy religiously too, but I'm saying
like if you tried to paint him as something he wasn't,
unfortunately, I I feel like Ben probably does support some of
the crazy like the settlers and stuff. So, oh boy. >> Or
they want to live. I just think generally speaking, you should
try to avoid dehumanizing language. Especially if we're talking
about religious groups or or these kinds of things. But I'm talking
ethnic groups. I just think it starts to get a little problematic
when you start using dehumanizing language. There's a way to
express your contempt or your dissatisfaction or your anger in
ways that, you know, don't trip you up and make you go on defense
when people call out that kind of language or say that it's like
dancing a little too too close to anti-semitism. You know, opinions
about that and I'm allowed to joke about that. And that's what
Hassan was doing when he was calling them inbred. Okay. Like
again, I'm I'm so sick of the fake outrage. I'm so sick of it
where we have a de Listen, I I'm just trying to keep listen again
scaling. I am allowed to do 1,000th the racism to orthodox Jews
and ultraorththodox in Israel that secular in Israel do to them.
Okay? 1/ 1,000th. I will I will stray no further, but keep in
mind that they're just overtly, extremely, and virulently anti-semitic
to these people. Okay? In like the craziest of ways. Ed president
likely has Alzheimer's who's this close to nuking an entire country
of 90 million people and we're supposed to talk about Hassan
Piker's jokes and be outraged. I can't them hutch. Who cares?
Avoid dehumanizing language when it comes to fundamentalist groups
who in action do disgusting things. I'm sorry that's baby. I'm
just saying in terms of like I'm making a practical argument.
I'm making a tactical argument. It's not nec I'll be honest.
I
I don't understand. I really don't. I don't understand how you
could
honestly try to say
that Hassan's rhetoric towards
Huh. I'm trying to think. >> No, no, no, no, no. I'm there's
like a comparison I'm thinking about. I'm not going to do it
though. I I need to think >> I'm just saying in terms of
like I'm making a practical argument. I'm making a tactical argument.
It's >> Oh, we have another hour for sure. I don't know
why. >> Probably will just call you more cause you more
headaches. Like I don't think that Hassan was talking about all
people in Israel.
I don't I I don't I don't think he was doing that. Like I think
he was very clearly not doing that. But you give people like
Fox News ammunition when you use dehumanizing language in that
kind of way. >> Case in point, Ethan Klein on orthodox.
I'm good. >> And then the conversation turns into something
else something else entirely. >> I can't bro. >> Annexation
of Crimea was out. >> Twitch literally had to change their
hate conduct rules to accommodate the exact example Hassan uses.
Zionist. >> Absolutely a justifiable annexation. What do
you call Crimea? I call it part of Russian territory. I call
it cry a river. A Russian river. The look that's
That's pretty disgusting.
How can you claim the moral high ground talking about Gaza in
the way that you have over the last few years? But you think
that's funny? You think Russian and violent imperialism is funny?
Like I don't
justifiable. He's joking. What do you mean he's joking? He's
not joking. Assad was not joking. He said it. He used colorful
language, but he was very honestly describing his apathy, his
lack of any kind of care about the Russian invasion of Crimea.
He's not joking about that. What are you talking about? >> Annexation.
What do you call Crimea? I call it part of Russian territory.
I call it Crimey a river. A Russian river. The annexation. >> Look,
he's joking. Now, to be fair, he absolutely was incorrect with
his prediction of what would happen. >> He's not joking.
What are you talking about? He's joking.
Excuse me. I don't think Kyle, like, frankly, I don't think Kyle
watches a lot of his hunt.
You know, Kyle was doing all this stuff about like, well, if
you watch his stream for one or two hours, then you know what
he's about. But I don't think Kyle watches a lot of Hassan. I
think Kyle probably
just mostly sees clips. I don't think he watches Hassan for more
than two or three minute clips on social media. I thought Kyle
literally said he does watch Hassan.
Weird. >> What is this? >> Okay. B-52 bombers are
departing RAF Fair for Ford in the in the UK with multiple aircraft
fueled and loaded on the tarmac. The first B-52
departed around 3 hours ago around a six 7-hour combat flight
from Fairfield to Iran would put the lead aircraft in striking
range approximately 2 hours before Trump's 8:00 p.m. Eastern
time deadline expires. I don't see eight engines. Is Yeah. Is
this a Is this a B-52?
What does a B-52 look like? that Russia was not going to invade
uh Ukraine. He was wrong, by the way. Pat myself on the back.
I kind of thought they were. I didn't understand why people were
going out on a limb and
>> I heard it. I heard his voice. I'm I must be obsessed
with this guy cuz I hear his voice all the time. >> He
thought that Russia was not going to invade Ukraine, which he
was wrong, by the way. Pat myself on the back.
>> The real way that Who is that? >> I thought they
were. I understand why people were going out on a limb and saying
like they're not going to invade. Well, then why they doing the
troop build on the border, right? So, I think he was factually
wrong about that. that he would admit he was actually wrong about
that. But this just sort of sounds like jokes and I think it
>> didn't he come out recently and say like I was wrong
but I was still kind of right. Didn't he just I swear I saw a
clip of him saying like I wasn't even like technically wrong
wrong about that. He didn't like fully he thinks that >> he
said something stupid about it. I >> that is in my opinion
justifiable. It is a part of Russia. Okay, you might not believe
it. >> I I just listen
maybe if it's something they stand on if they don't come out
and like
I don't even know >> people of Crimea agree with it. So,
I don't give a I don't care about what Not a joke. He's not joking.
It's not a joke. I don't know what >> how many times
How many times can you go back to the same clips again and again
and again? >> Oh, he would call that a joke. >> I
can't bring them up sometime. >> There's another clip literally
from
like just recently. Um, hold on. If I do search Crimea Hassan
responds to those calling out his past Crimea take here, it's
this one right here. >> What is this? the the Ukraine takes
galore. Buddy, buddy,
no one cares. The irony is like my Crimea position is like established
as as fact now. Okay. I don't even I I really don't even understand
what that means. Like your position is fact. Like your your opinion
that Crimea the invasion of Crimea was justified. That's now
established fact. >> I don't know why.
I don't know why. >> I'm pretty sure he's trying to say
that his analysis in the situation was correct. Yeah, there are
still
like Ukrainian influencers that are like, "Oh, it's our opportunity
to once again talk about Hassan and claim he's like super pro
Vladimir Putin or whatever." >> It's just this is a this
is a lost >> In some ways, it's identical to uh >> I'm
losing steam on this. I might have to find something new to cover.
>> We did a whole hut stream. I want to do a whole hut
stream. What the >> the way people talk about Israel and
like defending Israel in the Western world, you know? >> I
don't even >> It's It's so so ridiculous. Okay. >> Beyond
words. I nothing about that was a >> At this point, uh
Hassan, if you were to ask him, I think he would say, um, no,
Ukraine has every right to defend themselves and Ukraine in this
instance are the victims and Russia is the imperial. No, you're
just factually wrong about this.
Just factually wrong about this.
Just show me one clip of of saying anything that sounds like
this. Now, now I'm thinking of the clip of him on Adam Freelance
podcast where Adam Freeland made what sounded like a joke. I
don't know if he was being serious, but he said, "You know what
about Ukraine? Sounds about white." And that's like, "No, no,
no, seriously, though." >> He is sweeping you guys.
This is um he's putting on a master class for for sweeping for
for Hassan here um on the topic of Ukraine. >> Who are
you going for in Ukraine? >> I dude Filmont Filmont
all of this stuff. Filmont all of this stuff. I guarantee you
Hana said like at least five times
Ukraine should be invaded. It's like a war of aggression. I >> What
side you on on that? I'm I'm on I'm on nobody's side. >> Hold
on. We just got to justose this. If you were to do the troop,
>> I don't know how. By the way, do I have to do I have
to pull the numbers up again? I have to pull the units of evil
up again for Russian civilian kills versus IDF civilian kills.
How many civilians have been killed in Ukraine? Hutch, what do
you think? >> Right. So, I think he was actually wrong
about that. Maybe he was actually wrong about that. But this
just sort of sounds like jokes. And I think at this point, uh,
I think I I think he's on Russia's side. Just to be clear, I
don't I don't think he wants to I don't think he feels fully
confident and comfortable fully committing to that. I think he's
on Russian Russia side.
and what he did was wrong.
You are so brave. You think Ukraine guys are like Gaza? I would
be. They're like, damn, they they're cl they're clout >> Yeah,
there's a weird predicament cuz like Zilinsky is like super pro-
Israel. >> John Stewart. He's a John Stewart of >> That's
true. He was he used to be. Um but but he's like he's like has
to be super pro Israel because like he's pro NATO. He's pro like
American State Department, right? And that's what the American
State Department is signing signaling that they're like >> does
what does Hutch think this thinks this means or what does Hutch
think this means? Meanwhile, in the early stages when Russia
was invading Ukraine, Silleski was like, "Hey, can we get the
Iron Dome? Like, that would be nice. They're shelling us like
non-stop." And Benjamin was like, "No, he stopped it." >> You
know, all this stuff. >> Yeah. It's our It's our tech as
Americans. Like, it's our tech to give to Ukraine. And Benjamin
was like, "No, >> you know how I feel about Ukraine versus
>> No, sounds about white, dude.
>> Not my problem. >> That's That is not my problem.
>> It's just so gross to me, you know? And then they they
>> he's talking about that Zilinski's just got to dance
to whatever tune the Americans want almost all the time. And
it's a little bit tragic because it literally doesn't matter.
It like like he it doesn't matter what his opinions are. You
just have to dance because you need your weapons and your country's
existence depends on it. Like that's the that's what he's saying
there, isn't it? Is he saying anything else
that like Zillinsky just has to be like a puppet has to dance?
Is that not what?
Ah, my brain. My brain. What is this? Leed speaks. Nali hasn't
yet. Oh, about the ceasefire. Let's go. Hold on. Y laid. This
is, by the way, this is the moderate Israeli. Okay, this is the
moderate guy. Hold on. We don't show translation yet. Do not
read ahead. This is the guy that they say will pull them back
from all of these wars. Who is going to switch everything up?
It's going to totally change the country. This is the furthest
left candidate that has any chance at winning leadership in Israel.
Okay,
this guy
is the least pro-war candidate possible. less pro-war than than
Netanyahu. Far less pro-war than Nfali Bennett. Let's give it
a shot. Let's see. There has never been such a political disaster
in all of history. Israel wasn't even at the table when decisions
were made concerning the core of our national security. The military
carried out everything that was asked of it. The public demonstrated
amazing resilience, but Netanyahu failed politically, failed
strategically, and didn't meet a single one of the goals that
he said that he himself said. It will take us years to repair
the political and strategic damage that Netanyahu wrought due
to arrogance, negligence, and lack of strategic planning. More
details later today. Doesn't seem like it's wrong that they were
bombing Iran. Honestly,
I dude, I will need to see I'll need to see this ceasefire stick
in some way. I'll need to see this like actually be something
Israel is mad about to not think that this is all again theater.
Hey, maybe baby maybe
maybe
try to claim higher like the the moral high ground on their specific
form of activism and advocacy for for Palestinians in Gaza. They
try to claim the moral high ground and then they're like joking
and laughing. It's like funny to them what's happening in Ukraine.
It's like a joke. It's like literally a joke to them. It's so
>> I think you admit this because it's true, right? It's
true. In this does he
understand
that the Ukrainians have the capacity to fight back?
Does that change anything for him at
Like it it just feels like you're trying to do this comparison.
Ukrainians strike deep into Russia now. The Ukrainians actually
are able to do things to Russia. They're able to fight a war
against them. Palestinians were never even afforded that opportunity.
Like sorry in in like the most recent time
they're they basically been blocked from weapons by the entire
world. They have no ability to actually defend themselves. no
true capability of defending themselves.
I just don't understand why the comparison's made that it's like
the same thing.
>> Scenario like Russia is Israel and Ukraine are the Palestinians
and so if you support fighting oppression, you would back the
Ukrainians, right? Black people care about the border. I don't
give us what black people care about. Black people care about
this. Black people, this is like completely out of context. If
my memory serves me right, he was going after Black Ma being
like, "Oh, I don't care what because there's some black people
who are war hard right here. That's supposed to like stop me
from I don't think that's true. I don't think that's true. Is
he just filling in the blanks himself here? I don't think he
was talking about Black Ma. there's like five black magnet people
in the entire country opposing them like [__] that
these black people that's what he was that's what he meant and
again he just he's just literally just like assuming things and
filling in the blanks that's like so um my biggest complaint
about Ky these days is the dishonest framing you know that he
tried to like sound the alarm about Trump that drives me more
insane than anything else but my second biggest complaint about
Kyle is that he just seems so lazy like I don't think he's
No mirror posting again not again
no way he was saying I don't care what you think black people
care about oh I see >> a lot of him really trying to inform
himself about the things that he talks about. I mean, how could
you? I mean, this guy's uploading like 10 videos a day and so
it's like it's just turn churn turn ch turn ch turn ch turn turn ch turn
ch turn turn ch turn. You know, you just got to turn out that
content, but he's just so lazy. It's just so lazy and the stuff
that he talks about. Like why would you not, you know, you fired
up your your camera and OBS, I assume, and you're recording this
video and it didn't occur to you to like just why are you even
guessing? Just look it up, you know? Like you could find the
answers to these questions, but no, he just fires up the camera
and goes and then this drives me >> I'm afraid of like
he's racist against all black people. [__] this is
so hard. >> That like shut the [__] up how
politics work. And then I don't know if this is my I don't know
how to I'm not going to rank these, but this one's a real doozy.
Date rape is better if it happens to rich women. If you have
>> I was think I was thinking like how's Kyle gonna defend
this one cuz that one was [__] disgusting. >> I
mean
that's one of the ones that's easier to defend, isn't it? >> Should
have occurred to me that he's just gonna laugh at it like it's
funny. But that that's not that that is such a disgusting thing
to say. >> Billionar wasp fans at least taking them out
of other colleges. >> Listen man I you know if you want
to be edgy like super edgy like I just you >> I'm not going
to rank these but this one's a red billionp taking them out of
other colleges.
>> I So again I believe that's a lie in the quote if I'm
remember remembering correctly. Am I Am I making this up? I'm
pretty confident that that's a lie in the quote. No,
that that he doesn't say date does he say the words literally
date rape is better if it happens to rich women. I feel like
that's the context of the quote. No, that people are trying to
say he said that, but it is like it's actually better if it happens
within the context of like some upper class instead of it being
done on people who are already like under the boot of capitalism.
Like that's the that's the context of what the quote means. Uh,
probably stupid to say.
I'm not sure I could throw the first I I'm not sure I could throw
the first stone on that one. Yeah, I'm pretty sure he doesn't
say those words precisely. Uh, but I what do I know? I was just
the pre-minent Hassan A log for a long
>> I like how Tim just taking this all in. >> Of
course, a little bit better. >> I'm positive. Well, I'm
not positive. You know, I don't know him super well. I don't
know him at all. Actually, I don't personally know him. I'm going
to guess that Tim would be pretty disgusted by that comment.
And Kyle somehow thinks that Tim is just like internally dismissing
all these things. Tim in that again in that conversation they
had with Sarah Longwell. Tim was making a strategic tactical
assessment of how you go about attacking someone like Hassan.
That was my read from it. Tim was not saying like, "Oh, Hassan,
it's no big deal. Everything's fine." Like the stuff that he
says isn't that bad. That's never been what Tim has been saying
in all the clips in all the videos that I've watched and I've
actually watched the whole videos. You know, I listened to his
entire conversation that he had with Sarah. Well, I thought he
made some good points. I mean, I understand the
>> Bro, what the
he saying? >> I'm just laughing. I'm just laughing at your
streamer getting banned, man. No need for slurs. What the What
the What the heck?
What the hell? What the hell,
>> dude? That's rude, man. >> Sorry. I I was looking
at my notifications for a second that
I still can't go this place. This is a crazy [__]
clip, you guys. That's not how politics work. And then I don't
know if this is my I don't know how to I'm not going to rank
these, but this one's a real doozy. Date rate is better if it
happens to rich women. If you have these [__] millionaire
billionaires fail sons, at least taking them out of college only
to date your millionaire failed daughters in some respect, you
know, for utilities. >> I like just taking this all in.
>> Of course, a little bit better. Okay. Perk told all
the list condemned to the massacre on October 7th a blood. >> So
to my knowledge like again now I want to hold on to Tim Miller
>> Sarah Longwell take a stand
impure thoughts or something. >> This is one of my defenses
also defends myself is that if you're streaming 8 hours a day
like I feel like the critics that sometimes like look at the
like like an eight word snippet of something somebody says I'm
like you talk for eight hours a day. I just talked for one hour
day last night and I rewatched that video and saw pure thoughts
and that's what I was trying to say. You know I was trying to
you know I was trying to say >> so he's talking about a
specific thing like that he said that people had an issue with
>> you talk for >> No he's talking about in the context
of like multiple years of streaming 8 hours a day you will probably
say totally insane things at least one or two times and so your
worst clips are probably pretty bad and that his clips although
they would be less bad than Hassan's are still probably things
he wouldn't stand behind so he's not going to hold all of those
quotes to Hassan >> for a long time and >> yeah you
don't accidentally say Americans are >> no no he has some
very bad takes in there too very push can I push back and say
they're not takes like This guy has a worldview. >> Yes.
Yes. Yes. If you guys haven't watched this conversation, >> a
worldview that okay, >> between the two, I appreciate the
fact that I had this conversation in public. I think I'm going
to be like a both sides guy here for a second. I'm going to say
they both made interesting points. He made some points. >> Daughter
is in some respect for >> I like how just taking this all
in. >> Of course, a little bit better. Okay. Becker told
off the list of the >> So, did Kyle take somebody sorry
Hutch just took somebody laughing at Kyle's fake laugh? the the
laugh he's doing and Hutch assumed that was about him and then
they clarified it was about Kyle and then he rewound and started
pointing out Kyle's fake laugh
a blood blood thy violet pig dog suck my dick okay so that's
the back that's the guy >> I don't think any democrat should
look to include him in their coalition um and here's the book
at the top I just wrote a whole book that is about is 300 pages
so how do you know that one is 300 pages about how you build
a winning coalition >> you gave Kamla bad advice you are
the last person we should listen to >> did Sarah Longwell
advise the Kamla campaign and official capacity.
>> I think it was her friend that advised the Kamla campaign
in an official capacity, right? That was behind the Cheney linkup
and sort of this pivot rightward. No. What is what is he referring
to when he says that? >> Man's cozying up to people like
Hassan [__] I talk a lot about big tents. I talk
a lot about prodemocracy coalition. Here's thing. Hassan [__]
doesn't actually belong in the promocalition. >> She's
doing the talk fear. You're not a real Democrat, which no, he's
saying you're not listening to her. She is stating an objective
fact. He is not pro liberal democracy. He's he's objectively
anti-liberal democracy. This is just known. He's not he doesn't
hide this. This is just very unamiguously the stuff that he believes.
>> She again she came yesterday TO THIS >> IT'S not
about She didn't say he's not a real Democrat. Although she would
be correct in saying that he's not even a Democrat. He's not
a Democrat. That's not controversial to say either. But that's
not the point that she was making. She was saying he's >> illiberal
guy. He's a China Russia sympathizer who hates women, hates Israel,
he's all the toxic things. And I think and I was listening to
you last >> Hutch. We're going to push back against that,
right? Or are you going to do the thing that everybody does and
sort of glaze over the the things that you kind of disagree with,
but you're going to let them slide? >> Right. And I was
like, my biggest problem with it cuz I bring you my biggest problem
is I thought you were soft selling who this guy No, you were
smearing him and you're lying about him >> Oh my god. >> I
don't know if it's dishonesty or laziness with Kyle.
>> It's it's one or the other. You know, every every time
sometimes it's laziness, sometimes it's dishonesty. >> Finally,
let's get to the heart of the matter here. The real truth of
the situation. This is what Sarah Longwell really believes. Here
we go. >> Um, but here's the thing about the cheering that
I loved. Uh, speaking of Stonewall, but also I should point out
this was just before the election. Right before the election.
Okay. >> Oh, I think it's amazing when you get 75,000 presumably
lives on the Ellipse and she's like, "We're going to have the
most lethal fighting force." People are like, "Yeah." >> So,
she loves it when Kamla sounds more like a waronger than Trump.
That's what she's describing here. So, presumably it stands to
logical deduction. She would hate it if was out there like, "But
I'm anti-war. We're not going to go." >> Oh my god. There's
a there is a meaningful difference between saying that the the
military that she will be the um the commanding officer of
Wait, is that the what do we say again? >> I forgot the
line. Give me the line. Give me the line, dude. Where's the chank
rant? The chank rant about like the people on CNN and how much
they get paid. Just put it on the teleprompter, man. I I can
read the teleprompter. Just put it on the teleprompter. I don't
have my own pays. Just give me Just let me read the teleprompter,
dude. How do we describe the president's in their relationship
to the military? There's a term for it.
>> Commander-in-chief. That's what it was. Commander-in-chief.
Um, there's a difference between someone who is going to be in
charge of the military. Saying that the military is going to
be the most lethal ever. There's a difference between saying
that and I'm just itching to go to war. But in his mind, he can't
process the difference there. Um, paradox with $5. IMO has to
defend us on here if it's okay.
>> Saying you have the most lethal military is more than
saying you're the
>> Come on. >> Assan. What would that mean for? I
don't think he's worried about that at all. I mean, I think Kyle
has such a long track record of Kyle's kind of like the South
I would say Kyle's kind of like the South Park of political coverage
where he's been pretty edgy the whole time and so if he was going
to get like cancelled then, you know, it would have happened
by now. Kyle's also not um attaching himself to specific candidates
in the way that >> get a burger.
>> Kyle, I would say so. Yeah. >> And then Hassan's
also just, you know, I think Kassan's just got a bigger audience
than Kyle collectively across all platforms. I don't think Kyle's
worried about being cancelled.
I don't think that's true. I would imagine Hassan and Kyle are
about the same size. No, like it's difficult to translate video
views to like live viewership. And live viewership is big, but
I get the feeling that if Kyle was streaming consistently, he
would easily be at minimum half of Han's size like concurrent
at minimum. And I think he could easily work himself up there.
I'm pretty sure Kyle is like massive though. Kyle gets like millions
of views a month. I think I it's Dude, he might get tens of millions
of views a month. Be honest. He puts out like two or three videos
a day. They all seem to do better than 100,000 views.
Uh I can't do math right now. >> I think he would welcome
the coverage. I think um I think this is just about
>> Does he see the irony of him moraling about other content
creators being edgy when he's on this pesty plantation?
No. Cuz what he says is, so his response to this is something
along the lines of, "Yeah, but when Destiny said that he wants
Republicans to be scared and that like it's, you know, they should
be scared of getting killed when they go to things." Uh, I called
that out.
That's his thing. It's like, okay, what about when he called
the woman who's shared donentially a gold digging clout obsessed
who was her way up the streamer ladder? The person you said was
your friend Pixie. You call that out?
Did you call Did you call that one out or No, you just we just
let that one slide. Oh, we just let that one sl I get it. See,
cuz I I feel like that's probably worse on a on a Hutch level.
That should probably be a little bit worse than some of those
Hassan points.
shouldn't that feel worse to to Hutch here? But maybe not. Maybe
that's just totally fine. Well, again, Oh, he's done it like
a hundred times now. I think he knows that by making this kind
of video, there's a decent chance that Hassan's going to pull
it up on his stream. Like, I think that's probably what he was
thinking about. Um, remember Hassan, he's got the carrot and
and he's got the
And these creators that are in that same kind of space, occupy
the same kind of space, they're all well aware of Hassan's carrot
and Hassan's stick. Well, maybe I should use a different analogy
here. Hassan's got a shot collar and he's got doggy treats. And
if you make videos that are favorable to Hassan, he'll give you
some doggy treats. He'll pull up your video. He'll like spam
a link to it, tell everybody to go subscribe to it. And if you
criticize him or don't sufficiently defend him, he'll use the
shot collar. Go to war with
>> I I personally find the shot color stuff like not very
funny. It's not like the worst. I guess I guess war she lead
into it. Sometimes you go back to the classics. I just I whatever
fighting force and like yeah and she's like and we are going
to secure the border and people are like yeah. >> So defeating
MAGA by doing MAGA defeating MAGA by >> being MAGA like
wanting to have a secure border is as much about avoiding humanitarian
catastrophes as it is.
What am I trying to say? like when some people want borders.
>> It's just like he's
in a totally reactive way. He's just reactively pushing back
against anything Kyle says. Like I I disagree with Hassan and
Kyle on their rhetoric around the border. I don't I think you
do talk about securing the border, but it's like
yeah, I I don't know.
I still I think there's